instead of viewing Islam Marxism atheism
as the major threat to their religious
liberty they view Christians as their
main threat and consider us to be under
the influence of Satan as you saw in the
last part ironically their organization
is definitionally an accuser of the
Brethren which is Satan
[Music]
what's
up the channel so we're Contin
ues final part here in Examining The
Gospel of Jesus Christ up and against
the Adventist gospel if you miss the
other parts I suggest you check those
out first the link to those is in the
description box down below in the last
part we talked about what they call
apostate protestantism and how fleeing
from Protestant churches into the
Adventist Church is a part of their
gospel message today we're going to talk
about the third Angel's message which
has to do with the mark of the beast and
Seventh Day Sabbath observance if you've
ever wondered why Adventists can't seem
to control themselves when it comes to
inserting The Seventh-Day Sabbath into
every conversation regardless of the
topic in view stick around and you will
see why so before getting into it let's
look at Revelation 14 9-12 and then get
into their application of this it says
and another Angel a third followed them
saying with a loud voice if anyone
worships the Beast and its image and
receives a mark on his forehead or on
his hand he will also drink the wine of
God's Wrath poured full strength into
the cup of his anger and he will be
tormented with fire and sulfur in the
presence of the Holy Angels and in the
presence of the lamb and the smoke of
their torment goes up forever and ever
and they have no rest day or night these
worshipers of the beast in its image and
whoever received the mark of its name
here is a call for the endurance of the
Saints those who keep the Commandments
of God and their faith in Jesus so I'll
quickly note that most Adventists are
going to quote this from the King James
because like with the phrase Everlasting
gospel in verse 6 they've also latched
onto the phrase the faith of Jesus if
you cross-reference this with other
translations you'll see it translated as
faith in Jesus but because this isn't
what they mean when they say the faith
of Jesus they have latched onto the
kjv's rendering more on this in a bit
the SDA Church sees the third Angel's
message as a warning against receiving
the mark of the beast which they claim
will be worshiping on Sunday by
submitting to a Papal decree when a
national Sunday law is passed which will
eventually turn International according
to their eschatology the final battle
between good and evil will be fought
over the day of worship those who keep
The Seventh-Day Sabbath will receive the
Seal of God while those who observe
Sunday will receive the mark of the
beast in Adventist vernacular Sunday is
the papal Sabbath this is why their
narrative around the papacy changing the
Sabbath is so important to their
framework they claim that all the world
will unite under the leadership of Satan
to impose these Sunday laws upon
Seventh-Day Adventists eventually Sunday
laws will be passed requiring a death
sentence for anyone who refuses to
worship on Sunday and now I wish I were
kidding in the great controversy on page
615 Ellen White writes this
as the Sabbath has become the special
point of controversy throughout
Christendom and religious and secular
authorities have combined to enforce the
observance of the Sunday the persistent
refusal of a small minority to yield to
the popular demand will make them
objects of universal execration it will
be urged that the few who stand in
opposition to an institution of the
church and a law of the state ought not
to be tolerated that it is better for
them to suffer than for whole Nations to
be thrown into confusion and lawlessness
the same argument many centuries ago was
brought against Christ by the rulers of
the people it is expedient for us said
the Wiley Caiaphas that one man should
die for the people and that the whole
nation perish not this argument will
appear conclusive and a decree will
finally be issued against those who
hallowed the Sabbath of the fourth
Commandment denouncing them as deserving
of the severest punishment and giving
the people Liberty after a certain time
to put them to death romanism in the old
world and apostate protestantism in the
new will pursue a similar course toward
those who honor all the Divine precepts
or earlier in the book on page 450 she
said this in the issue of the contest
all Christendom will be divided into two
great classes those who keep the
Commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus and those who worship the beast in
His image and receive his Mark although
church and state will unite their power
to compel all both small and great rich
and poor free and bond to receive the
mark of the beast yet the people of God
will not receive it so remember earlier
what I said regarding the phrase faith
of Jesus this is why in Adventist
vernacular this phrase means that you
have a faith identical to that of Christ
completely unwavering Faith just like
Christ had regarding Revelation 14 9-12
their claim is that the worship of the
Beast image will be if you worship on
the papal Sabbath once this decree comes
down so the flip side of this is where
they get their theory around The
Seventh-Day Sabbath being the seal those
who in the end times supposedly are
keeping the Ten Commandments perfectly
and have the faith of Jesus will be
given the Sabbath seal despite Paul
explicitly saying that the Seal of God
is the holy spirit they believe it is
The Seventh-Day Sabbath in letter 98
from 1900 she says this
the Lord has been pleased to give his
people the third Angel's message as a
testing message to Bear to the world
John beholds the people distinct and
separate from the world who refuse to
worship the Beast or his image who bear
God's sign keeping holy his Sabbath the
seventh day to be kept holy as a
memorial of the Living God the creator
of Heaven and Earth of them the Apostle
writes here are they that keep the
Commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus
so verse 12 then becomes a key text for
them when they hear the word commandment
they always think ten commandments so
this phrase Commandments of God in their
minds are those who are keeping the Ten
Commandments perfectly and the faith of
Jesus is those who have a faith not just
in Christ but a faith at the level of
his thus they will then ask what church
is keeping all ten of The Commandments
and not just nine to segue into why you
need to join their church because
they're upholding all of the Ten
Commandments supposedly in their minds
this only further solidifies The
Seventh-Day Sabbath being the final test
in the end I'll do a separate video at
some point in getting into this further
and how outside of their unique
historicist approach to Revelation this
whole Theory crumbles but again I want
to ask you is this the gospel remember
this is all a part of this Everlasting
gospel that they claim to be restoring
the biblical text says nothing of the
sort regarding a national Sunday law of
The Seventh-Day Sabbath being the Seal
of God or anything about protestantism
the Adventist Church by means of Ellen
White have written themselves into the
narrative as the last day Crusade
leaders of truth instead of viewing
Islam Marxism atheism as the major
threat to their religious liberty they
view Christians as their main threat and
consider us to be under the influence of
Satan as you saw in the last part
ironically their organization is
definitionally an accuser of the
Brethren which is Satan and they see
themselves as holy other and the
Pinnacle of Truth Ellen White really
unloads the canon in spiritual gifts vol
1 on page 190 where she writes this
I saw that since Jesus had left the holy
place at the Heavenly sanctuary and had
entered within the second Veil the
churches were left as were the Jews as
they were filling up with every unclean
and hateful bird I saw great iniquity
and vileness in the churches yet they
profess to be Christians their
profession their prayers and their
exhortations are an abomination in the
sight of God said the Angel God will not
smell in their assemblies selfishness
fraud and deceit are practiced by them
without the reprovings of conscience and
over all these evil traits they throw
the cloak of religion I was shown the
pride to the nominal churches God was
not in their thoughts but their carnal
Minds dwell upon themselves they
decorate their poor mortal bodies and
then look upon themselves with
satisfaction and pleasure Jesus and the
angels looked upon them in Anger said
the angel their sins and pride have
reached unto Heaven their portion is
prepared Justice and judgment have
slumbered long but will soon awake
vengeance is mine and I will repay saith
the Lord the fearful threatenings of the
third Angel are to be realized and they
will drink the wrath of God in
innumerable host of evil angels are
spreading themselves over the whole land
the churches and religious bodies are
crowded with them
so if you're a Christian remember this
when you hear Adventists call you
brother or sister but it doesn't end
there the third Angel's message
supposedly even includes their message
of Health reform she writes this
the health reform I was shown is a part
of the third Angel's message and is just
as closely connected with it as are the
arm in hand with the human body I saw
that we as a people must make an
advanced move in this great work
ministers and people must act in concert
God's people are not prepared for the
loud Cry of the third Angel they have a
work to do for themselves which they
should not leave for God to do for them
he has left this work for them to do so
tied to this third Angel's message of
Seventh-Day Sabbath keeping is also the
dietary lifestyle prescribed by Ellen to
the Adventist Church vegetarianism
preferably veganism add this to the list
of doctrines for their Everlasting
gospel to recap worshiping on Sunday
will be the mark of the beast the
seventh day Sabbath is the Seal of God
Adventist message of Health reform must
be followed non-sda churches were
rejected by God like the Jews were they
are full of vileness their prayers are
an Abomination Jesus and the angels are
angry with them they will suffer the
wrath of God and evil angels crowd these
churches so in its entirety between all
three of the messages that Encompass
this SDA Everlasting gospel you have the
investigative judgment young Earth
creationism leaving apostate
protestantism and joining the Adventist
Church the spirit of Prophecy supposedly
manifests in the writings of Ellen G
white The Seventh-Day Sabbath and their
message of Health reform this is not the
gospel folks this is a result of a
movement that started based on a false
date setting prophecy that some people
refused to accept they were wrong about
which resulted in a doctrinal mess I
hope the series was informative for
Christians and you guys are better
equipped now to engage with Seventh-Day
Adventists knowing where they're coming
from and can take the true gospel to
them if you enjoyed today's video please
be so kindest to smash that like button
subscribe and ring the notification Bell
so you can be notified when content like
this is uploaded I'll catch you guys
around next time God bless
thank you
[Music]